(techno music)
- Today, we are going
to be smiling all day.
Whatever we're doing,
we're gonna have a big smile on our face.
- I don't really think I smile.
I try to avoid it actually.
- I also smile when I'm
trying to alleviate tension
or awkwardness.
- I've learned throughout the years
that some people are scared to talk to me
or think that I'm unapproachable.
I didn't realize that my default face was.
- I wanna find out if it's true
that if you smile all the
time it makes you happy.
Is happiness just a muscle contraction?
- I think I wear my
emotions on my sleeves.
If I don't like someone, you'll know,
but I feel like it's a skill
not to like someone and still be like,
"How are you doing?"
I wanna be able to mask it when I want.
- I think I'm literally
gonna look like the joker.
- I'm scared that my smiling
face will look creepy.
- Also worried that I'm gonna
feel like a big old phony.
- I'm gonna go sit down at my desk
and just smile at my computer.
- Smiling and working.
Just keep smiling,
smiling, smiling, smile.
- It's really nice.
Seeing you happy makes me happy.
- I walked into the room,
and I was like, there's something great
and even more pleasant
than usual about him today.
- Liz was telling me about how
her dad forgot her birthday.
Not a funny story, but I
had to smile through it.
I felt so awkward.
- It seems more like I
have my life together,
and I'm just like a happy
person all the time.
- You know how like
when guys on the street
tell you to smile, and
you tell them to fuck off,
I guess they won't do that anymore,
'cause they have no reason
to tell me to smile,
'cause I'm already smiling, bitch.
- It's a hot day in this sweater,
and I'm just smiling,
like nothing is wrong.
- [Armand] Do we look
happier as people right now?
- You look like you're in pain.
- Yeah, I'm definitely in pain.
It's really painful to have your lips
out like this all the time.
(playful music)
- Other than the cramping
that's happening in my face,
I think it's kind of
effecting the way I feel.
Convinces me and my body
that I'm having a great time.
- I do feel like I have
a lot of energy though,
which is weird,
and I think it's because
I can't relax my face.
- It's really weird smiling,
because I'm listening to some
super angsty emo music right now.
To properly enjoy my angsty music,
I have to be brooding,
and I can't do that.
- In the middle of eating lunch,
I realized that I lost my phone.
I'm hoping that it's at the office,
even though I'm slightly panicking,
'cause all my credit cards are in there.
You can't tell, because I am smiling.
- I'll have a negative
thought about something,
and then I'll feel my face
kind of melt into a frown,
and then I'll pick it
back up into a smile.
It stops me from having
a negative thought.
- It's like a workout
on my face and my soul.
(playful music)
- Just finished a meeting
smiling the whole time,
and the person giving the presentation
did say I looked creepy, but.
How's me smiling nonstop?
- It's a little bit disconcerting,
because I feel like
usually when people smile
it's in reaction to something.
So they're smiling,
because they just saw you,
or they're smiling because
something made them laugh.
So it's weird to look over at you,
and you're already smiling.
- I'm saying hi to people more often.
I don't know what it is.
I think having a big smile might make me
a little more welcoming.
- [Kane] Is the way you
perceive me slightly different
with me smiling?
- Yeah, yeah, completely.
- Yeah, you just seem like warm.
- You just like welcoming.
I saw you smiling, and
then I smiled instantly.
- [Kane] How much more welcoming?
- 48%.
- Enough for me to talk
to you, and be like "Hey."
- Surprising.
- People should smile.
- I'm surprised.
- Everybody thinks I'm like
super excited to see them,
but I'm not, I'm just smiling.
Nobody actually believes me anymore.
I tried to say something to somebody,
and they were like, "Is this a joke?"
and I was like,
"No, I'm being completely
serious right now."
- I'm noticing that all my
interactions with other people
have been pretty great so far.
Being a smiley person makes
all of your interactions
with other human beings very pleasant.
Who'd have known?
In like subtle ways,
it's helped me kind of get out of a slump.
Next time you're in a
bad mood, try grinning
and see what happens.
- Smiling makes other people smile,
and it makes other people happy.
It makes you more approachable.
- I got a lot of mixed
reviews on the smiling.
Some people thought I
was more approachable.
Some people though it was creepy.
Even though I did like
being more approachable,
at the end of the day, I'd
rather be liked by a few people
but stay real, than by a
ton of people and be fake.
(upbeat music)